et maintenant c'est un lâche et voici
alexandre jardin
jardin bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir j'ai
publié à la rentrée chez grasset un
bouquin qui s'appelle roman des jardin
est en tête des ventes depuis ça a été
tirée à 100 mille exemplaires déjà cent
mille exemplaires réimprimer ça sort
32000 par semaine 1
ça laisse rêveur invectives c'est un
énorme succès faut dire que ce coup là
vous y allez pas de main morte à vous
fait des révélations très sulfureuses
sur votre famille un peu comme julien
clerc
vous vous mettez à table alors fini
l'auteur bien élevé du zèbre de fanfan
du vial vous dites j'ai joué la comédie
pendant 15 ans j'ai pantoufler
bourgeoisement bien sûr que ça vous a
pris quoi mais j'avais des raisons aussi
c'est à dire que j'étais issu d'un tel
chaos de folie et de way fois-ci de m'en
sortir je me suis composer un personnage
qui me qui m'a permis de tenir qui m'a
permis de survivre alors qu énormément
glandes de ma famille ils sont morts en
chemin et c'est vrai que là est ce que
vous êtes
réfugié en fait dans les romans assez
assez sage pendant pendant des années
pour pas être influencé pour vivre tout
ça est alors françoise verny qui a été
votre votre accoucheuses 1 vous disais
toujours mais quand elle disait un
bouquin de vous chérie où es tu là
dedans quoi elle trouvait françoise
verny que vous aviez une vie un peu trop
sage
elle attendait le moment où j'écris un
ce livre là elle ne verra pas non
manon mais c'est si ce livre est sorti
c'est aussi parce que j'ai fait une
rencontre très forte avec un éditeur il
ya à peu près un an
c'est une histoire absolument
invraisemblable je marchais sur
boulevard saint germain et je
téléphonais qu'un éditeur chez grasset
et tout à coup il me dit écoute je suis
obligé de te laisser parce que je suis
au ski au chili et méfiance est
maintenant en bas de la piste
il raccroche juste avant j'ai eu chili
mais personne ne skient au chili et dc
si on accroche je fais 100 m et je le
vois traversée boulevard saint germain
je sais pas jean paul enthoven
s'ils n'y a que lui pour faire et je le
vois traverser le boulevard saint
germain sous mon nez je me précipite je
me retrouve en face de lui
je le regarde et qu'est-ce qu'ils font
chier il vient vers moi
non non non non encore mieux encore
mieux il me dit alexandre mon cher
alexandre situe à + fois en tes yeux
quand ma parole de ne pourront plus
avoir de rapports de confiance
je les regardais et là je me suis dit
j'ai ressenti exactement la même chose
en face de lui que ce que j'avais
ressenti à 20 en face de vernis c'était
je me suis dit je tombe sur quelqu'un
qui est tellement romanesque que c'est
l'éditeur que je cherchais depuis un
moment et je lui ai dit écoute j'ai un
livre dangereux pour moi à écrire j'ai
l'impression d'être en train de
rencontrer mon éditeur est-ce que tu
accepterais de devenir mon éditeur et là
il ya une réponse sublime ai dit écoute
je rentre non non non non presque où il
a dit écoute mais pas loin
tout a dit dès que je revient du chili
je t'appelle de l'aéroport et nous
signons et donc je suis tombé sur un
type sympa quand même un homme génial
personnage absolument génial tellement
jardiner sq c'est à dire qui
correspondait au fonctionnement des
membres de ma famille et je savais que
cet homme là ne me lâcherait pas et et
m'interdirais d'arrêter l'écriture de ce
livre que j'ai déjà commencé deux ou
trois fois oui que j'ai que je ne
parvenais pas à terminer alors vous
raconter tout on connaissait votre
grand-père le
nain jaune évidemment ancien directeur
de cabinet de pierre laval à vichy
réfugié en suisse après la guerre mais
là alors on le voit carrément dans votre
livre donner des valises de billets à un
frère qui soit parti de françois
mitterrand c'est une soirée mitterrand
ce soir non mais c'est incroyable mais
en fait gamin - je voyais je voyais au
fond la réalité de la vie adulte
c'est avec la plupart des gamins ne voit
pas ça et chez nous on voyait tout ce
que normalement un gain à gauche ne doit
pas voir et donc je voyais effectivement
mon grand-père si distribuer les
valoches de billets que c'est un grand
entremetteur de la quatrième république
et je voyais effectivement une sorte de
faux mitterrand puisque c'était un de
ses frères mais qui ressemble
étonnamment à son frère et moi j'étais
môme je voyais les affiches du candidat
en 74 dans la rue et je me disais je me
faisais ça incroyable et ressemble
vraiment à l'autre et surtout ce qui
était extraordinaire quand j'étais gamin
c'est que je voyais ça je me disais mais
il doit vraiment pas avoir confiance en
sa bande puisqu'il envoie son frère
bah oui non mais ça me semblait ça me
semblait des faits du coup j'avais une
vision du monde adulte assez
particulière alors dans ce livre on
découvre votre grand mère surnommée
l'arc buses alors évidemment personnages
extraordinaires qui dort fenêtres
ouvertes en rêvant qu'un cambrioleur
lubrique va venir là la rejoindre qui
dit que le latex et malsain et qui
fabrique des préservatifs en boyau de
porcs qui demande à ses enfants à ses
petits enfants quand ils font l'amour de
taper sur le radiateur pour que toute la
maison en profite
achetez choisir une poésie qui soit mais
du coup moi je tapais comme un fou sur
les radiateurs dès que je rentrais dans
ma chambre près et et qui fait inhumé
dans le caveau de famille le perroquet
de paul morand dont on apprend qu'il
était son amant donc c'est vrai que le
rocket man paul morand
ça répète les efforts ordinaire quoi
mais c'était des gens qui fonctionnait
surtout elle avec des principes
extrêmement fort puisque elle était
contre le travail par exemple admise et
je suis contre parce que le travail
éloigne des hommes des femmes et et
lorsque je vis l écoute c'est un peu
facile quand même ton mari aglietta vie
tout le temps 1 1
elle me répondait mais froidement amusé
je ne le lui pardonnerai jamais c'était
l'idée d'être raisonnable il semblait
une forme de déchéance et miou miou
d'une certaine façon un julien mais elle
est toute simple pourquoi je comprends
pas mieux a toujours gagné sa vie ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'un menu elle
voulait travailler justement alors que
l'état des cavaliers c'est rodez doit
écouter vous m'avez torture et de
maintenance et son tour elle a fait
aussi bâtir au fond du jardin un cabanon
au bout dit avoir vu défiler tous les
hommes politiques de la quatrième qui
fait des choses pas très racontable il
ya eu un couple que j'ai trouvé tout à
fait extraordinaire parce que moi je
grimpais sur le toit on le disait pas
tous les adultes mais évidemment monde
sont regarde toujours à travers les
serrures nous on monte et et ont regardé
ce qui se passait il ya eu un couple
c'était un vieux diplomate qui un jour
revient avec sa maîtresse et qui se fait
fouetter
bon on regarde ça on était à peu près
dix ans je file voir ma grand mère je
lui explique
elle m'explique que les côtes et à la
fin de l'été je vois les pousses du
vieux diplomate qui revient avec un
jeune mexicain plutôt sexy elle se fait
également attachés avec des menottes et
fouetter et là on n'a pas compris
pourquoi ces gens ne faisaient pas sans
famille
les cds c'est à dire qu'au fond on a eu
accès très tôt à l'envers du décor alors
grand mère je continue parce que ses
équipes selon tes n'y a dans le ventre
un ver solitaire pour pouvoir manger
tout ce qu'elle veut et c'est moins cher
à sortir qu'un chien et compagnie qui
m'a elle avait des animaux domestiques
extérieur et interne qu'elle appelait
zoé
voilà et elle a dû vivre à peu près sept
ans exo et qu'on a dû finalement tuer
etc on a inhumé au fond du jardin
voilà avec les droits dites vous il ya
aussi les amis de la famille c'est à
dire une salle qui est un juriste pis
paul héroïnomane
mais on apprend en lisant le livre qu'il
était sise au fil qui couchait avec sa
guenon qui l'habille est d'ailleurs en
femme et la guenon était elle-même
héroïnomane aussi aux défis qu'elle ne
supportait pas se piquer seul et mais ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'il était
critique à madame figaro et et pour
acheter son héroïne
il a écrit pendant à peu près 15 ans
toutes les lettres d'une revue
pornographique s'appelait union il
écrivait tout le courrier
les réponses du sexologue les titres les
articles de fond est gelée su parce
qu'un jour il m'a fait venir c'était à
l'époque où j'avais publié enfants et il
m'a fait venir il m'a dit voilà je je
voudrais que tu me succède et
c'est quoi que je lui succède et je lui
ai dis franchement je ne le sens pas je
et c'est ce jour là que je me suis rendu
compte qu'ils vivent est excellent que
non car je revenais de hautain or là il
ya votre oncle aussi donc le merlin
alors lui ce pont est alors il ya un
petit problème parce que dans une
première version vous dit que quand il
se pend il est travestir en femme mais
dans une deuxième version big les
équipes edel mécanique
non c'est faux ce que je dis non c'est
pas faux pourquoi pascal des problèmes
avec la famille
j'ai préféré me
j'ai préféré modifier je préfère tout ce
coupé ouais il ya eu des problèmes avec
la famille les manger j'ai pris cette
décision moi il ya eu des problèmes la
famille a réagi comment la famille a
réagi d'une façon complètement double il
ya eu tout ce qui est au fond on
attendait ce livre ouais
ma mère par exemple m'a dit profondément
c'est formidable que tu l'écris
et puis il ya eu tout ce que je
comprends qu'ils qui ont été dans le
déni et je les comprends parce que j'ai
été comme ça pendant 20 ans ouais
c'était que je peux pas leur jeter la
pierre
cependant 20 ans j'ai essayé de jouer au
gendre lit ce qui devait vous énerve
oui oui mais j'ai comme j'ai été ça je
comprends parfaitement qu'un certain
nombre de demandes de ma famille
aspyr ait besoin de nier entièrement
c'était cet ouragan de folie quand les
fans jardin le fils de votre oncle
merlin il a réagi comme en lui de cette
façon là et je le comprends parfaitement
il est là si stéphane jardin
valmont soir il est donc le cousin
d'alexandre jardin
alors vous êtes très en colère parce que
vous dites tout est faux l'essentiel il
faut il n'y avait pas de cabanons pas de
thénia pas perroquet pas deux mais je
respecte parfaitement ce discours
profondément ce que vous dites vous ce
que vous dites vous le stéphane c'est
que les préservatifs en boyau les
radiateurs le perroquet le ver solitaire
le cabanon le grand-père qui donnait des
valises de billets offerts de mitterrand
il sale blague non et héroïnomane tout
ça vous dit c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai vous êtes donc dans le déni ou
c'est vraiment pas vrai nom c'est
vraiment pas vrai je pourrai proposer 10
témoignage derrière moi si vous ne
souhaitiez si c'était nécessaire c'est
c'est pas me proposes et le problème
n'est pas venue de ce qu'alexandre a
écrit alexandre a décidé d'écrire un
roman il s'appelle le roman des jardin
et j'étais tout disposés et c'est pour
ça qu'ils d'ailleurs il a jamais eu
d'action en justice à ce jour contre lui
avait concédé le droit d'écrire un roman
simplement toute la promotion a été fait
sur c'est la vérité à l'instant il vient
de vous assurer que tout ce qui vient de
vous dire est vrai or une fois encore
c'est faux cancer en hyper j'ai dit
c'est grave pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement dans ce roman il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments qui sombrait
en règle générale des drames
qu'alexandre comme nous un mal vécu mais
aujourd'hui je peux pas laisser mes
enfants et les tiens non plus
découvrir leur famille avec ce regard là
pour moi c'est un livre psychanalytique
et cet endroit absolument le plus strict
simplement
t'as pas le droit de dire que c'est la
vérité t'as pas le droit de faire croire
à l'ensemble des gens qui regardent des
émissions de qualité dans votre audience
qu'il arrêtait tout d'abord je voudrais
dire une chose c'est vrai que c'est un
roman mais pour moi un roman ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est quelque chose qui
raconte des choses fausses
un roman c'est précisément un mensonge
qui dit la vérité
je vous donne un exemple le mois dernier
il ya un magazine suisse qui voulait me
photographier chez moi or il se trouve
que chez moi ça ne ressemble pas aux
maisons jardins de mon enfance donc j'ai
demandé à mon éditeur jean paul enthoven
de me passer sa maison qui ressemble
étonnamment jusqu'à l'odeur fada
mandragore j'ai fait venir un magazine
suisse
j'ai changé les sonnettes on a fait des
séances de photos on a fait l'interview
et puis à la fin de l'interview j'ai dit
écoutez j'ai dit la vérité
je suis rentré cinq minutes avant vous
la journaliste ne m'a pas cru et demain
cru qu'en sortant au moment où j'ai
arraché les étiquettes
j'ai donné une photo qui n'était pas une
photo de mon véritable maison mais qui
était une vraie photo jardin
ouais c'est à dire que c'est
profondément ça un roman et d'ailleurs
il m'arrive en ce moment quelque chose
de tout à fait jeu qui me confirme que
j'ai véritablement écrit un roman qui a
une puissance de vérité c'est que c'est
un livre qui aujourd'hui s'exporte dans
le monde entier
c'était axis avait été un livre de
confessions tels que ma famille
l'heureux leur sang par ma famille dans
tel qu'une partie de nuit c'est à dire
que jamais ça n'aurait été traduit en
italien lésions
c'est à dire que les américains s'en
foutent complètement de la famille
jardin romanesque évident ça se vendrait
pas comme ça pardon excusez moi non non
c'est simplement parce que je respecte
parfaitement intitulé sur écoute c'est
juste par rapport à ce que tu viens dit
c'est toi qui écris que c'est une
confession c'est toi qui écris j'ai
longtemps rôdé autour d'un livre intègre
commencé dix fois m'atteler à cet
exercice de netteté c'est toi qui écris
donc hémorragie confection de confession
pourquoi s'obstiner à écrire si on n'a
plus rien et dissimulé autrement dit
tout ce roman tu l'écris comme si
c'était une vérité si je veux bien
admettre que soit ta vérité tu le
sous-tend quelquefois mais les millions
des téléspectateurs et ont vu expliqué
qu'ils avaient ri des études mais
regarde sur les relire les échanges
qu'ils sont et on est profondément s'il
va justement quelque chose où il n'y a
pas une vérité c'était le regard que
j'ai sur ma grand mère je pense qu'elle
m'a tenus des propos qu'il n'a jamais
tenus avec certains de ses fils sans
quelque chose à quelqu'un peut pas
déconner si l'enfant dans la cour deux
classes commencent à parler de mon père
pendu je peux pas et je peux pas trouver
que ta vérité soit très intéressante ni
bonne à dire ni été décidée le bon
moment pour dire les choses
la vérité c'est que c'est vrai qu'avant
d'écrire ce livre j'ai attendu vingt ans
ouais
la vérité c'est que je n'ai probablement
pas attendu assez longtemps par rapport
à certains membres de ma famille mais la
vérité c'est que par exemple ce qui a
été un véritable déclic de l'écriture de
ce livre c'est la décision de mon frère
frédéric déduire qu'il est le fils de
claude voilà voilà
et le jour où mon frère frédéric est
venu me voir et il m'a dit voilà puisque
fanny histoire est extrêmement complexe
mais mon père a voulu un enfant de
claude sautet
ouais ils formaient un couple a trois
avec ma mère et ils l'ont fait ils ont
vraiment fait mon frère qui est
biologiquement le fils de claude sautet
mais désiré par mon père et le jour où
où mon frère m'a dit stop
je veux être officiellement ce que je
suis pour moi ça a été une autorisation
fondamental que c'est là que j'ai décidé
tout raconte oui voilà et puis ensuite
j'ai rencontré rené dit que je comprends
pas vous n'avez pas fait lire à certains
membres de votre nom alors ses fans
dirait on n'a pas fait c'est sur un plan
personnel ça ça dépasse largement
pourquoi voulez vous
j'ai peur que si vous leur virilus
censure non parce que j'ai commencé à le
faire et j'ai fini par comprendre qu'un
livre c'est une voix et qu'un roman
c'est fondamentalement une voie que vous
ne pouvez pas négocier chaque heure
chaque passage c'est une voix c'est
l'affirmation d'une subjectivité
c'était comme mon regard sur ma grand
mère n'est pas une very n'est pas la
vérité c'est la mienne d'accord donc je
ne pouvais pas négocié pied à pied
sinon sourit un mot mot-à-mot c'était
pas possible c'était pas possible
finalement le seul problème que vous
avez sexy alexandre allait publier ce
livre sans dire que c'était vrai ça vous
poserait pas de problème alors il ya là
un roman sur le moment je n'ai pas vu ce
soir moi et parce que ce soir non ça
c'est sûr je serais pas venu non c'est
parce qu'il a crié que c'était la vérité
et puis parce que il ya des choses que
j'ai trouvée quand même proprement
ignoble non vraiment malgré tout dans la
façon de faire il faire passer une sale
pour un zoo fils alors lance ça c'est
vraiment vrai mais les vues de la part
romanesque il se trouve que c'est vrai
l'histoire de la guenon c'est vraiment
vrai comme vous dites mais c'est bien
pire
c'est à dire que parfois j'ai été obligé
de gommer toute une partie mais oui je
il ya plein de gens qui probablement en
lisant le livre se disent ils vrai
forcément ajouté mais en ce qui concerne
ils servent
j'ai dû diminuer parce que le personnage
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
ardentes a diminué mais oui évidemment
que ça diminue les certain nombre de
chose de ta vision
oui de ta vise les deux pas de la vérité
parce que en tant que lorsque tu dis
comme tu l'as fait souvent des émissions
c'est en dessous de la vérité c'est une
version lite situe précise pas c'est la
version lite 2 m'avait rssi de ma vision
les gens s'y perdent quand mais il me
dit au téléphone
mais le seul qu'elle bat stéphane les
journalistes ne croient pas un mot de ce
que j'ai écrit dans ce livre tu omets de
me dire à la fin de la phrase ça
s'essouffle et m'a dit pour nous
rassurer tu omets de me dire la fin de
ta phrase oui mais je vais faire tout ce
qu'il faut pour que l'ensemble des
français croire ce qui est dans ce livre
alors je voudrais dire une chose je t'en
prie que d'abord je trouve que chose
pour ça finalement très bien que vous
l'ayez fait venir
bien sûr non mais je trouve ça
finalement très bien parce que je
considère que une famille n'appartient
pas à un individu
moi j'ai écrit mon roman des jardin il
s'en est fait un autre et finalement je
trouve ça très bien que que chacun
puisse s'exprimer
et puis ce n'est une partie de mon livre
je trouve ça bien moi j'ai vécu huit ans
à l'as monaco
non mais 365 jours par an mais dont je
n'ai pas vu quelqu'un ce n'est pas moi
je plusieurs vérités au sein d'une
famille d'accord alors ce qu'est ce qui
va se passer maintenant bon goût c'est
ce qui va se passer
rien ouais qu'est-ce que vous ayez qui
se passe je ne veux juste pas j'ai
entendu parler d'une rumeur de film je
me mettrai en travers évidemment si
jamais c'était le cas je veux drake
alexandre arrête d'écrire sur notre
famille que ou alors qu'il fasse un
roman à clés comme ça a été pendant des
siècles mais oui mais aurillac jardin
votre oncle il pas content non plus
impopulaire oui ta mère et de ton frère
qui bottent en touche mais sans sa
personne et que oui mais en dehors de ce
qui est fondamental pour moi
d'accord les les faits a créé ton clan
et nous n'existons plus alexandre c'est
ça que tu nous as fini avec ce livre
c'est ça que nous a dit devant tout à
pronos c'est ça qui nous a dit tout le
temps on n'existe plus pour toi et toi
fais tourner je peux pas t'empêcher de
penser ce que tu pense et je respecte ce
que tu dis non merci
mais bien les choses autour d'un gigot
dimanche sinon je viens vous pensez
avoir des réactions sur le livre qui va
sortir sur vous non oh non monsieur je
supporte comme ça si c'était un truc
quand même
j'adore la crème fouettée c'est le scoop
du livre j'ai quelque chose a ajouté
stéphane je crois que j'ai dit
l'essentiel à alexandre est à vous
si j'ai été entendu c'est parfait
l'issue aurait été entendu merci merci
beaucoup
non non
monsieur
sa première fois que vous le voyez
depuis que l'avion est sorti oui j'ai
essayé de joindre et ils ne répondaient
pas un merci d'avoir été avec nous